[Music]
okay I look like I've been attacked
that's not my fault well I know it's my
fault to me even out the bottom can
would you just stop carving tacos I'm
making sure it's everybody likes short
what that feels awkward we won't stop
pulling my pants off
what are those what don't stop it
so my Spanx they hold everything
together why what's gonna come popping
out
[Music]
belch was a fireman oh yeah but it's
okay okay even I'm pretty pretty intense
she doesn't care accident last year he
injured his male parts
they're just shredded down there and now
he can't work he wants to fight fires
and he wants to be stood it up she won't
beat it up I know you do but he can't
he's bring to sue I get it I get it
I want you to know I protect and serve
your martial style what not an Air
Marshal I'm gonna take a nap awesome
cool I'll take the first watch I'm not
an Air Marshal
there's no but you don't need to take a
watch okay
[Music]
[Music]
how about a beer Oh whiskey no oh my god
you're pregnant I'm driving a car
[Music]
[Music]